oye 5 et 3 5 et 3 ans du mocratie c'est
par le référendum que s'exprime la voix
du peuple
dimanche votez votez avec nous le
pouvoir est à vous oyez oyez ça fait 3
en démocratie c'est par le référendum
que s'exprime la voix du peuple
dimanche votée la différence par rapport
aux autres c'est que nous on s'engage
réellement à inscrire au conseil
municipal les pour et les contres des
habitants d'avoir des discutions
contradictoires et de valider la
majorité de ce que veulent les habitants
je pense que d'avoir 10 % au premier
tour on nous prend quand même au sérieux
on parle beaucoup de démocratie
participative
mais en fait nous on ne veut pas
participer on veut décider c'est tout à
fait différent de décider et comme on
est nombreux
c'est par le mode du référendum que la
décision de la majorité doit se faire
entendre
et ben là je on va tracter pour les
personnes de saint clair du rhône par
des habitants faut qu'on ait des
habitants de cinq heures du rhône pour
leur dire qu'on est au deuxième tour
pour les municipales de saint clair donc
et leur présenter le rique référendum
d'initiative communal donc il s'adaptera
à la commune ces citoyens donc on a
juste mieux le jaune pour qu'on nous
voit mieux et qu'on nous entende mieux
donc là on est des citoyens lambda on
travaille on paye des impôts 1
on est d'accord et donc maintenant on en
a marre donc il faut qu'on reprenne un
peu la boit on leur explique sur la
liste ce comment veut on envisage le
rique référendum d'initiative communal
comment on envisager comment on envisage
de le mettre en place
donc ils comprennent très bien et ils
sont ok ils sont pas légion en fait ils
sont prêts ils sont prêts à donner leur
avis donc en a beaucoup qui ont baissé
les bras parce qu'ils croient plus en la
politique
cette politique qui détruit tout et on
voit bien le résultat avec la crise
sanitaire semble un exemple donc non il
faut souvent que ça change donc ça va
mettre du temps des années mais on est
là pour interpeller les consciences et
éveiller les consciences si on peut se
permettre de faire quoi
dimanche votez votez avec nous le
pouvoir est à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]